so that's an example we want our
children right to have a love of
knowledge so we should bring them around
the people of knowledge like did Subhan
Allah why do our children these days
they have a love of
actors they have a love of
influencers they have a love of
athletes right they can tell you about
athletes they can tell you about how
many games how much they make where do
they live this that that and then you
ask them about one of the sahaba tell me
about Abu Bakr
silence tell me about Omar
silence tell me about Abu
silence tell me about an
athlete they go off no know everything
about the athlete how much he makes what
team he was previously on what team he's
currently on how many games how many
shots how many this so you know
everything about my dear brothers and
sisters what is an athlete going to
benefit you on the day of
judgment what is an athlete going to
benefit an actor what is an actor going
to do for you on the day of
judgment and you find Muslim kids saying
I love so and so I love
they're saying the actor I love this
actor I love this comedian I love this
athlete and they don't know anything
about the
sah they don't know anything about the
scholars of
Islam
IM but then you say an actor an athlete
they become
happy this is deficiency in the home
it's mentioned in the life story of IM
Ahmed in the
book that is mentioned by his son either
Abdullah
or the sons of IM Ahmed and IM Ahmed one
of the greatest Scholars of
Islam his son said
whenever whenever there was a person of
knowledge visiting my father I was
father would bring us and introduce us
to him because our father wanted us to
have love of the people of
knowledge Our Father wanted us to have
love of the people of knowledge so
whenever IM
Ahmed who died 241 H and we're
in, 144
what5 IM Ahmed died 241 we're talking
about 1,200 years ago and IM Ahmed is
teaching us how to raise
children his son is saying whenever our
father had a guest from the people of
knowledge he would bring us some of us
we when we do that if there's a lesson
there's a conference we let the children
play outside go play outside they're
young right I'm going to the Masid I'll
let them stay
home Imam Ahmed whenever he had a person
of knowledge in his company he would
bring his children
and his son is narrating it so his son
understood and IM Ahmed disclosed to his
children because his son said our father
brought us to meet the individual
because our father wanted us to love the
people of
knowledge he wanted to instill in us the
love of the people of knowledge so this
is very important my dear brothers and
sisters and then we wonder why our
children are on the internet and they're
having being very fond of Jordan
Peterson or very fond of this individual
and that
individual but when it comes to the
great Scholars of Islam they don't know
them I have to sadly say that's not
their fault that's our
fault what have we done to make sure our
children love the scholars of Islam my
dear brothers and
sisters do we
realize and this is one of the things
Hass said in his lecture
yesterday that people don't
realize how
tremendous the Heritage that has been
left by the scholars of
Islam I'll say it again he said it in
the lecture yesterday people don't
realize how tremendous How
great is the Heritage that has been left
by the scholars of
Islam an example of that can you
imagine tremendous great universities as
are uh considered in the
west right in the UK you have Oxford
University you have Cambridge
University right here in America you
have Harvard you have Yale you have uh
MIT you have New York University right
do you know that those universities have
departments for Middle Eastern studies
and they translate books
ofl and and other great Scholars of
Islam they translate those
books inshallah when the brothers in the
future and the sisters they visit the
library that we're starting Islamic
library in New Jersey Beav we have
translations of the books
of the books
of
the books of IB
rajab the books of IM
Ahmed by these ivy league
universities by these IV league
universities why because they realized
these books had strong knowledge and
wisdom so if they are able to identify
that the books of IB are filled with
knowledge and
wisdom the books of filled with
knowledge and wisdom the the books ofb
filled with knowledge and but the
Muslims don't realize it our kids don't
realize it the kids they want to go to
these universities these universities
have translates translations of these
great books of Islam they realized
filled with
knowledge so how another question that
we ask ourselves how once one how don't
our children know about these Scholars
but the universities know about these
Scholars right that's one
two how are these books present in the
universities but they're not present in
the homes of the
Muslims if they acknowledge this
knowledge why don't our children
acknowledge these acknowledge this
knowledge that indeed is a deficiency
within
ourselves